can anything be done to stop the misery
of human trafficking our special
correspondent Alex Crawford has been on
the trail of the world's most wanted
people smuggler and Alex were going to
see this on a documentary sky one at ten
o'clock tonight we'll see it tomorrow
night on Sky News at 9:00 o'clock before
we talk about whoo-hoo there says let's
take a look at the doctor from a
war-torn nation on the verge of collapse
we go on the trail of the world's most
wanted human trafficker did they see the
people who organized it for them
from his desert hideaways in the depths
of the Sahara
to his secret bases on the Mediterranean
coast
we expose the inner workings of an
international criminal network this man
has been paying prison guards so that
they can carry on smuggle into Europe
but with the traffickers operating in
one of the most dangerous places on
earth we ask
chance of stopping this
okay this is one man we're talking about
he is the king of people smugglers of
human traffickers and it's a big problem
for the European Union it's top of
political agendas as well how did you
find out about him well he's quite well
known it's he's one of the godfathers of
people smuggling probably the most
wanted man involved with people
smuggling in the world today and
everyone knows him everyone knows him
who wants to get to Europe he wants to
be smuggled out of their country so and
there are thousands of people who are
fleeing poverty and also oppressive
regimes in Eritrea Ethiopia so he's not
that hard to to actually find out about
because he is such a huge figure in
Libya and he's hiding there beyond the
reach of international law the
difficulty is bringing him back to face
justice who is he and how much are these
people worth to him how much is this
business worth to me the business is
worth millions I mean he is a
multi-millionaire and so is his network
and he's not just one person he's a huge
network across a number of different
countries with money being transferred
so this is a business this is a massive
business and he's the CEO of it and he's
not the only one doing this business
because that is the growth industry in
Libya it is people smuggling and it's
easy to hide in Libya because there are
areas of the country that are completely
unreachable you've managed to travel to
parts of the country lengths from the
breath of it there no other Western
journalist has managed to do will you
hit the nail on the head it is
impossible to actually track these
people down because the country is a
basket case and this is one of the
investigations that the Italian police
it's the most comprehensive
investigation ever done into people
smuggling it's more than 700 pages worth
of evidence they haven't been to Libya
the team and I went into Libya and
tracked this man's smuggling route
picking it up from the Sudanese border
and going right across the length and
breadth of Libya which
is a horrendously difficult journey and
dangerous very dangerous disease and for
you know everyone involved in it can you
tell us if you find them you're gonna
have to watch the documentary yeah you
know that you need to I think you need
to watch this relatively short program
which tries to have a multi-faceted
approach and show you just the huge
problems involved and tacking this this
and how we found that there is
corruption at almost every level that
these poor people are being exploited by
almost everyone and going through
horrendous things torture beatings rape
virtually every woman that is smuggled
will have been raped probably many times
the conditions that they're in and the
vulnerability and the the the sheer sort
of desperation of these people is is
pretty awful and I'm actually trying to
tackle it by the time they reach Calais
or Britain is far far too late and
approaching it from a completely wrong
angle because the problem is all in
Libya is there any justification for
what he does mean you know you've just
given this an awful description there
does this man see himself in any way was
offering some sort of service that no
one else does he definitely feels that
he's offering a service and in fact you
know that's quite interesting because my
young daughter my 13 year old daughter
said why why is it wrong because these
people want to come through well the
exploitation is wrong and almost
everything that's happening to them is
out of the parameters of normal behavior
you know these are hundreds of people
thousands being locked up in the in a
multiple number of places you know
they're not proper jails they're not
we call them detention centers then that
gives it an air of some sort of official
capacity it's not they are basically
huge kidnap houses
yeah pens and we're women men are locked
up by men with guns
but can't get out and these people can
do whatever they like are you in any way
hopeful that you have done something or
something will happen as a result of
your investigation that the Italian
police for instance have not been able
to achieve oh listen
always hopeful because you can't carry
on unless you're slightly optimistic but
it's there are so many problems and so
many challenges it really needs a
multinational approach okay well you're
going to start with your documentary
Alex there she's on the trail of the
world's most wanted people smuggler it's
sky one tonight it is 10 o'clock Sky
News you can see it tomorrow night at 9
o'clock here the lots of is special they
have coverage on Sky News tomorrow from
6:00 a.m. with all of this thanks very
much indeed Alex thank you